ah ah ah está um vídeo especial eu
gravei um vídeo colhida com vocês tanto
subiram deixa o boca do hype publicada ó
[Música]
321 o lado pessoal de quem fala é o dar
que sejam muito bem vindos de mais um
para com isso a mim e os tratados aqui
um desafio vocês tanto pediram que é o
tenta não morreram e em um evento atrai
nas lado e tentando rir vai ser um
desafio diferente porque não ajuda se
iremos fazer uma coisa diferente para
não ser igual a gente mata e nós vamos
usar argila na cara por quem não sabe o
que quer gila é tipo uma pasta fosse
junto num copo e pois mantém na cara
para as mulheres ficarem bonitas já
tenham tido uma foto no instagram
basicamente nós vamos ver vídeos de
coisas engraçadas de um desafio é tentar
não viram com argila na cara vai ser
difícil para caraças porque ficar papel
e nós vamos por ser um eficiente somente
três vezes perde o desafio e quem perder
o desafio a outra pessoa mais claro um
desafio extra para essa pessoa cumprir o
desafio de ter perdido o desafio
anterior é para esquecer o guarda então
o que é isso
o que é estupro desde o astro que vai
ter que devolver o dinheiro com medo e
com um pneu uma é colher e é muito bom
mas vai ter sim uma sopa
então é isso o alvand inter agora a vila
vamos ter que fazer ainda por que não
procurar nada e quando nós tiveram lhes
foi fazendo agora chega expresse
copagril fãsico desafiou joão paulo foi
tranqüilo em campo deu bola para dentro
mas sim nós temos interesse na cara faz
bem o papel
agora tá wonton sentir a textura
primeira aplicação
[Música]
gosta do jeito como o funk não sou um
tipo de teatro sesi ática seja certo que
quando apoiava então tem preço
[Música]
é isso que acontece com o que tem de
fazer
oi que é uma
[Risadas]
[Música]
em 2000 esse número e da madeira isso
sou médico no mesmo camarote vai cuidar
com o que tem de fazer
agora vamos pra kisseque e já o câmbio
[Música]
safe to do autor sol plantou há um ano
[Aplausos]
[Música]
não tô na rua 2 longe
foi como no rio de janeiro não tem graça
não é muito para um vídeo no qual a
oposição sul ante qualquer pessoal do
leão não olha não é que desde que fazer
um tour começa trazendo músicas quando a
música o cantor aposta vocês nunca viram
um ano com uma máscara de gosta de um fã
que é isso
[Música]
eu nunca pensei fazer turmas que estava
ruim
então é isso pessoal vamos ficar por
aqui com esse desafio já sabem se
quiserem vir mais coisas aqui no canal
deste ano claro diga nos comentários que
vocês queiram querem que a gente faça
nem por twitter um vídeo engraçado para
nossos filhos se o campeão luta estava a
dizer olha pra mim a dívida eo produto
está dirigindo lançados para nós tiramos
depois mais tarde fazemos um trailer 98
risos 2 é espero que vocês tenham
gostado das sugestões novos tinham
chance e é isso que temos por aqui esta
sexta-feira a cidade passa pelo canal do
centro pior
a apo não tinha chance a um salto porque
é isso fique bem e até a falta